two
oh
thank
you well thank you all for joining I
apologize that I have not been around
and Brian is capable uh
um ability capable whatever to to take
care of things so you know what I'm
today good as you have been the last
month so
carry on so
um I don't see a whole lot of folks in
in the audience who are probably looking
to testify um I think we're winding down
with the uh folks who have concerns um
but um obviously if any of you are
interested we'll hear hear from you um
the
um there's a few issues that we do need
to address um uh and we will need at
least one Amendment maybe just just
maybe just one covering all the issues
something I was just talking to um uh
the Department of Labor about uh was the
concern raised last week from the
Department of Environmental Services I I
found it a very legitimate concern over
equipment that uh is manufactured
overseas does not meet um the OSHA uh
requirements um expensive equipment and
to require someone to immediately and uh
abruptly um replace perfectly good
equipment um is uh not what we're after
um so what we need to do is figure out a
way to accommodate the Department of
Environmental services without opening
the barn door wide open for anybody who
wants an exception to line up and say um
me too um so I think there's um my my
last words uh to Mr Gardner was um we
got to figure this out so we got to
figure that out
um another issue that we need to address
is the effective date um I think uh in
earlier um conversations we've concluded
that 60 days um is not a a good idea uh
we do need to give people more time to
get ready for this
um and
um that's uh a discussion I'd like to
have today to figure out um as we put an
amendment together um what the actual
effective date ought to be um you know
we heard something about five years um
that's too long um and uh and again
understanding that the department is not
uh I think think I said last week the
day this becomes effective there's not
going to be a starting gun go off and um
everybody is going to have to be perfect
on day one um the department will um
operate the way the department operates
that they're not a gotcha operation
they're a let's figure this out together
operation and um uh I think because of
that I I I'm not uh overly concerned
with um having everything perfect on day
one um but 60 days isn't right we got to
figure out somewhere between 60 days and
several years where we land um several
um and I do you want to talk about your
um thoughts on yeah whatever here yeah
um I I guess I'll ask U the chairman to
uh weigh in on something that he and I
were discussing um prior to the hearing
today so um take it away thank you thank
you
Brian um I have had an opportunity to to
briefly uh discuss this with the well I
probably have I haven't told you all the
things that that I've been doing let me
back
up so knowing I was not going to be
around uh a few meetings I did have an
opportunity to have relatively long
conversation with commissioner
Maryfield and um about this and about
1910 and you know I admit I have not
read all of
1910 and I don't want to I don't ever
want to get caught by saying well yeah
we passed something but I didn't really
read at all so I have a copy here if
anyone's really interested and and this
I don't know who did this but um um Rudy
Ogden provided us with a copy of 1910
and it has uh three different colors red
blue and green for items it may not be
applicable things that could be
applicable and non-mandatory things and
and I'm TR to take it upon myself to
read as much of this as I can because I
really want to be able to answer every
question I can if someone says to me in
the committee did anyone read this does
anyone know what you're asking us to do
here um but in the in the conversations
that uh I had with the
commissioner
um admittedly the department knows that
they haven't kept up with some of the
safety things as per I think current law
as say every two years or something
right now uh it was every year and I
think that was then changed modified
every two years and then you know things
happen and and it doesn't get done no
harm no fowl um but trying to implement
this entire law it would be relatively
impossible um to hand a binder this
thick I know you I'm I'm old so I
actually you know made a copy I know all
you young kids look at things in
computers now uh but my brain doesn't
work that way from screen to screen and
um what are the things that could we
break this down into implementing
something different each of the next
three years I would not be an advocate
for implementing anything as you said in
30 or 60 or 90 days nor would I say
we're going to pass this and nothing
happens for five years because you know
what's going to happen all of us know
that six months before the fifth year
whatever day day we do everyone's going
to um six days exactly everyone's going
to do it the last week and then say they
can't do it uh another thing that dawned
on me and I did not to speak with this
with Ken uh with the the commissioner
and I don't think I've expressed it to
anyone here um I don't think it's a bad
idea but I'm not sure everyone's going
to like
it I don't like when we mandate and
there have been some discussion about is
this a an unfunded
mandate to municipalities or to the
Departments within our state we do know
that there's a surplus every year that
the Department of Labor um turns back to
the general fund
and in my mind I thought well what's
wrong with implementing as part of this
law a 5050
Grant um up to a maximum allotted amount
of 500,000 per
year that could be utilized as an
application
basis to the Department of Labor to help
possibly mitigate some of the cost to
the municipalities in the state
um Departments of the state to purchase
new things that they need to uh there's
certain Machinery certain equipment um
so I'm throwing that out as an idea to
be
considered I do not want an
implementation of a long period down the
road I would like something where 1910
could be implemented in sections each
year for the next three years um as a a
way of easing in some of these things to
have it um done with obvious exclusions
for certain things U you know one of the
the things that um this these machines
have you know I don't know how
sophisticated these things are but if
any of you have ever worked in a machine
shop you ever see one of these things
where you have to have one hand here one
hand here and you push it with your foot
that way you can't get your hands caught
in it I don't know if it's that kind of
a machine where that's doesn't have
those safety mechanisms or not um I
don't know if you have any details on
that but uh I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't want if it was in the forensic
laboratory of the state I wouldn't want
all of a sudden we put something in
place where they can't do their jobs
anymore because we're going to hear
it so overall that was my thought now
how do we do this
um we would have to work directly Page
by page with the
Department to determine which things can
be implemented
uh uh the E you know the ones that are
the least costly and most easily
implemented the first year and get
increasingly more difficult to achieve
time is that something the department
can I I know you're just just hearing it
now um but um can you um share any
thoughts you might have um on that idea
of a uh graduated implementation uh
whether that makes it
uh uh easier for folks or more difficult
would it be better just to go with the
uh concept of um we're going to help you
get caught up as um as this
implementation happens or is splitting
up the uh standards into three uh
sections is that something that is
workable
throw you right into the fire
here so I think one of the potential
concerns without um you know digging
really into the 1910s is if there's any
sort of references throughout um you
know the other portions of 1910 other
portions of the OSHA law so um again
without digging in it's kind of tough to
say but I think that'd be one of the
concerns is how do we actually set this
up so there isn't any confusion there of
okay this has a reference to subpart s
in this one that we've implemented but
we have an implemented subpart at
actually
work um what are the employers actually
subject to so I think off the top of my
head that would be one of the primary
concerns which is something that
obviously we would have to figure out of
the feasibility of that um because again
I do know that there are references
throughout the oosha laws to other sub
parts to other um you know sections of
the law in general it it occurs to me as
well that um what this bill does is it
repeals the Department of Labor safety
standards um and implements the OSHA
1910 if you repeal the sa the the
department of labor
standards and only uh Implement onethird
of the OSHA standards um the gaps that
exist now get a lot bigger um because
you're going to have entire sections
that aren't have have no safety
standards yes and to that point there
may inevitably be holes um as you're
stating that uh you know all the safy
standards are repealed and if we are not
wholesale adopting 1910 if we're doing
it peac meal there might be sections
that you know if we don't do scaffolding
during the first Go Round And The
scaffolding portion is repealed there
may be no standards of scaffolding which
I think kind of goes against the intent
of the bill to make make more robust
standards why would you want to pass a
law
that wipes out what's being done now
because it's being replaced there are
scaffolding standards in OSHA there are
scaffolding standards in the um
Department of Labor um safety standards
but unless you this then this may make
it overly complicated you you would have
to leave
you you would have to do a partial um
repeal and a partial implementation
matching up the parts that you're
repealing and the parts that you're
implementing um over that three-year
period
um is it just me or does that make it
overly complicated for the Department it
has the potential too I I think again
the the real key piece there is how they
interact with each other um so you know
each implementation would require some
fairly in-depth analysis I would imagine
as to determining again how they're
going to interact with each other what
the employers are actually going to be
subject to and again I'd understand the
intent of the bill at least one of the
intents of the initial bill was to kind
of clean things up and you know put it
more out there so the employers are
aware of what's going on so I know that
the last thing any of us wants to do is
make it more confusing for employers as
to what their requirements are under the
law
one of the things that's coming back to
my mind um in this conversation and it's
something that I don't think I did
Justice and trying to explain to our
chairman when I was talking with them uh
can we go back and revisit the
conversation that we had last week
regarding the training um and the idea
of training some of the con concerns
that were were brought here last week
had to do with the additional costs
needed for training um and if we even do
this in segments you know there is going
to have to be a training you know I see
I foresee some training and you were
talking about the idea that some of the
um Tradesmen who are licensed um could
potentially be the trainers of the oia
standards am I understanding that
correctly I trying so yeah I I think if
I recall correctly what um the concerns
from some of the stakeholders were borne
out of was the fact that the training
requirements under OSHA might be a
little bit more stringent um and what
the discussion centered on and if I
remember correctly what I and it might
not have been eloquently testified to
and I do apologize if that's true um was
that Tradesmen may be um qualified to
train that's not a prima fascia case
that 100% say it's a plumbing um you
know Plumbing that they're training in
that if they hold a master plumbers
license it's still a case-by casee basis
um but I know that the concerns again
did Center on we might have to um
Outsource some more training which will
be cost you know to the
municipalities and they weren't entirely
sure what that training would look like
or who would be considered qualified
because while there is a qualified
person standard it is rather broad under
OSHA and to be honest with you I'm not
entirely sure how OSHA interprets that
um but but again the as far as
tradesman's go it would be one of the
piece of analysis and it would be a
case-by casee basis on if they are
deemed
qualified um and uh pardon me but is
there more to the question kind of you
know um I I might have misunderstood
where I'm going with this no but there
isn't I appreciate the qualific the the
qualifying on that because last week you
did leave me um a little bit distressed
over the idea having been a professional
in the trades um knowing that just
because somebody is licensed in the
trades does not mean that they are
qualified to teach OSHA of course yeah
and I apologize if that was I walked
away with that saying if I gave that to
five of my service technicians you know
maybe one of them could come out getting
some of it right but the other four
would not of course of course you know
when I was um licensed as an attorney
day one that doesn't mean I'm qualified
to train as an attorney so so you you
left me with that one hang the world
possibly think a licensed gasfitter
could uh be
it would be a piece of the analysis but
again it's not necessarily that okay
they have this license that's all we
need we would still have to vet that and
see you know if they do meet the
qualified person standard I think one of
the obvious pieces is that um you could
be one heck of an electrician a really
good electrician totally incapable of
exactly go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um during our talks with um Deputy
Commissioner Ogden and uh we have a new
gentleman here with us um today um if
there was no standard
in the do log um there was always
reference to a general duties
clause and where would you reference
that back to do you use the
OSHA no 1910 what what do you because
there was a lot of talk about going to
General duties and then looking for an
industry standard then going to looking
for OSHA I there's a misunderstanding
there so when it comes to um the general
duties can be found under RSA 281
a64 where it just basically says all
employers private or public have the
obligation to provide safe a safe
working
environment and they lists a bunch of
things that they should be considering
and doing like providing P PPE where
necessary um then so we would go in
under current standards we would go in
and do a safety inspection with our
safety inspectors and if there's not
something specifically enumerated uh
within the 1400 lab rules but we
identify a dangerous condition so um
there's a sinkhole in the middle of
their parking lot that doesn't have
guarding around it um I think that might
even be that's already in there um well
yeah it's a sinkhole so it's not doesn't
fall under um a confined space um but
they they need to address it we'll look
at it under
277 uh think 17 and 18 so those give us
the jurisdiction over on a public uh
employer for an additional Safeguard or
a modification to an already existing
safety program or
plan now when we look at that most of
the time it is not oia standards that
we're looking at it's usually some sort
of Common Sense thing that had been
overlooked you know you see a sinkhole
you need to address it uh if there's a
suspicion of mold growing you need to
test it to figure out whether or not
it's mold before you address it uh
because you can be addressing something
incorrectly or
unnecessarily um and so those are things
that not typically under OSHA it's more
of a common sense assessment of you know
how to adopt you know safety standard um
like for example um we had one in which
there was a loader um that we were invol
investigating a serious py injury where
it was reversing and it hit and rolled
over the foot of the um spotter who's
doing the directionals and when we
actually did the investigation what we
found out was there was a training Gap
he did the directional s single for uh
reverse when he meant stop when he was
doing hand signals um and you know this
had been something that had been going
on for a while uh between the man
supervisor and the employee where they
just weren't communicating well between
the two of them wanted recognized a
training Gap but it hadn't been
addressed so when we identified that we
added a an additional mod safety
standard of you need to complete a
training with this individual uh with
respect to proper hand signals for
directionals uh before he conducts this
be um activity again in the future um
and then is this addressed in your
safety program with respect to training
when should he have gotten this training
what did the training look like uh and
you know if he wasn't adhering to it
what are your steps to include
potentially discipline um so those are
things that are typically under this the
modification St and these additional
safeguards um now if it's something
that's completely outside we've never
seen before again rarely happens we may
look to OSHA for guidance but that does
often yep um so who sets the training
standards where would you look for that
the state if the state didn't have
something in that area where would you
look to find those training standards in
order to pass on to the uh municipality
that you would be investigating so the
training center so there are you know
Common usely used directional signals
for that we we would talk to the to the
employer and say you know how do you
what are your directionals how do you do
train for them and so it's the employer
who would be stating and this isn't in
OSHA either um but it would be something
in which the employer would State you
know we adopted these directionals These
are the signals that we utilize and
we're like okay how are you
communicating that to your employee how
are you training and then how are you
supervising to make sure they're
actually adhering it to it so that
everyone's on the same page and these
again good is it follow that's okay yep
on so but there needs to be some type of
goto when the state does not have an
industry an industry standard or a
standard within the do what is to say
that we cannot do the easy stuff first
without having a law to mandate you guys
to bring your standards up into at least
the 2000s or you know 2010 standards or
something like that into current
standards because we have building codes
that are current we have electrical
codes that are current we have food
safety codes that are current why do we
not have workers safety codes that are
current and ocean standards may not be
the you know is top tier why are we not
even approaching mid tier when it comes
to some of the safety
standards well I'm not saying we weren't
approaching top or mid tier it's you
know these are in instances in which
would not have addressed been addressed
by OSHA either proper training you know
I guess you know OSHA would say you have
to utilize proper training there's
something in there too but our standards
say the same thing so I don't think I
follow so the easy ones some of the easy
ones like not using an metal ladder when
you're working on electricity I mean
some of that stuff is common sense OSHA
says you have to use a certain type of
ladder certain type of foot SES um
certain type of equipment insulated
equipment when you're working on
electrical live electrical lines if our
standards current standards right now do
not address that and somebody is injured
during working on one of the Bridge
Project or lighting project where would
the state the inspector go to find those
standards to say this is what you should
be doing which is the correct U
procedures even though we don't have
those particular you know stringent
standards we can at least get you part
way to being more safe for your
employees it would just be the
additional safeguards in the sense that
you shouldn't be operating you know
around electricity without utilizing
proper safety gear to include not a
metal
ladder but where would you find those
standards where would you where would
you go to if the state doesn't have
1400 have something somewhere on that
already
so you know utili OSHA could be a
standard that we utilize but we also
look at the actual you have to operate
all equipment as it is designed to be
operated and a lot of the equipment
would say do not operate around live
wires so that would also be where we
that's one of the standards that we have
in our laws that operate equipment as
it's
directed I I I guess what we're what
we're talking about is the reason why
we're doing this um we are trying to
expand and provide more complete uh
safety standards
um and
um the difficulty is that we and and
we'll and OSHA included does not have
everything no standard will U provide
for every safety issue Under the Sun um
you know you're talking about sink holes
sinkholes are a problem but does any
safety Standard address sink holes
probably not um so uh the general duties
Clause is going to continue to be
necessary so that Common Sense safety
can be observed
um but that doesn't mean this uh effort
is not needed we we do need um more
complete safety standards and um this
bill provides for that so um I guess
that's why we're doing this and that's
not the position of the department we
take no position with respect to the you
know any laws that you draft uh or and
adopt I just wanted state that we do
issues I
I I guess I'm I'm I'm thinking that
there are
um some issues that we need to address
and I I'm wondering if we ought to be
addressing them offline to some degree
um the um we need to figure out the dees
exception issue um we need to figure out
whether graduated implementation is
feasible
um
inadvisable
um because I can see the potential for
it be becoming more complicated and more
confusing and people don't know we have
bigger gaps in our safety standards and
no one knows exactly what standards
we're using because part part of it's in
part of it's not um so um we need to
figure that out and um I think we need
to have some um uh probably some
in-depth conversations with the um
department on the uh the cost sharing uh
concept I suspect that might be a um uh
something that kind of goes to the top
um you you guys aren't authorized to
spend money are you
no it goes to the top house yes you're
um I I guess I entertain thoughts from
the rest of the U committee here as as
to um how we might uh do that I I one
possibility is that the uh uh
representative in infantine myself could
meet with the Department to try to work
these things out um aside from uh an
actual hearing um you know it would be
you know just the two of us trying to
come up with something that we would
then bring bring back to the
subcommittee um and eventually um before
too long we need to vote this uh this
bill out of the subcommittee and send it
onto a um executive session um but um I
think we've uh thrown some some things
up in the air that need to be resolved
before we can do that um do you have
that overall my thoughts are that we
currently have a law which requires the
Department of Labor to update their
safety standards on on a whatever
regular basis that is um for reasons
that that you know things happen it
hasn't been done I am not going to be
critical of the Department of Labor
because overall I think they do an
extremely good job here in the state of
New Hampshire but the fact is I don't
want to put a law in place that is so
voluminous that they're not adhering to
the law now and then we put something
you know so big in that it's still not
going to be I mean I I just I would
really like to know some of the details
all of a sudden the legislature passes
1910 as is what is the Department of
Labor going to do how many employees
they have to hire who's going to be in
charge of this who's going to know this
thing left and right how much is going
to be implemented what about the
training that's going to have to be done
by the do to allow uh members of their
own Department to come in and do these
things and and I'd rather have a much
more neat neat plan um more con clear
and concise plan um so we know exactly
what it is now you know
Department's you know very good you know
they their standard answer like many of
the other departments are we will do
what the law requires us to do
you know they're not legislators and
we're not administrators um but I just
want to make sure that we are not in a
situation where we Implement something
where the Department's not prepared to
enforce and we're having
municipalities um and Departments of the
state having to spend a bunch of money
to get up to a certain standard when no
one at the Department of Labor really
knows that standard yet because
someone's got to spend six months
studying it and figuring it out um it
just doesn't happen overnight where we
pass something and they know this
correct I mean no one's going to
memorize this
overnight
um so I want to make sure what we're
putting in place is actually going to be
adhered to and
and rolled out
correctly and we get up to a better
standard where we are today now that
sounds good I don't know how to do that
Brian that's yeah that's not our job
that's your job and so I guess I would
be delighted to hear some thoughts from
to what you what the department would
need to do or put in place in order for
this uh implementation and when when you
know the time frame I your uh input on
the effective date would be helpful as
well
and and a fair answer would be we're not
sure we have to figure that out um and
you know I my objective is not to put
you on the spot and say um we we want an
answer now to every question um but do
you have any thoughts on a I think what
the chairman is is indicating is is is
fair that basically we want a clean
implementation um what does the
department need in order to provide a
clean
implementation um so initially I would
say of course you know we would need
time as well um to your point
representative I'm not sure what the
time frame really would be at the end of
the day but our current safety
inspectors are trained on our safety
laws and they're trained on how to
research other safety laws but they are
not trained on OSHA so obviously any of
our safety inspectors any of our
administrative staff that handles this
stuff would have to you know spend some
time learning the OSHA laws training on
those um to be honest with you I'm not
entirely sure what that looks like um as
we talked about previously I think that
we would at a minimum you know even if
we're doing peace meal implementation we
would need some more um more staff um
one of the big pieces would be the
consultation program that is required by
an oosha state plan I know obviously
we've talked about we're not going to an
oosha state plan but inevitably we would
expect to see a lot of the stakeholders
be proactive and reach out saying hey I
know that this is coming we want to make
sure that we're good um which obviously
we all want that so again our safety
inspectors already have their own case
load as is this would add to that and it
would you know again add to the
consultancy piece in the sense that we
would expect um some sort of a Floodgate
to open where these stakeholders would
be seeking some input from us they would
be seeking much like we're doing with
the Department of Environmental Services
currently of going out there determining
where they're stand where they're at
relative to the current standards where
they're going to be at relative to the
new standards and what that would take
so um you know in short as you did state
representative a lot of this is
difficult to determine on the spot right
now it's something of course we can work
towards you know determining with our
commissioner and Deputy Commissioner and
our safety inspectors um but to the
question relative to time frame the
department itself would need some time
as far as implementation goes of course
as we've heard from the stakeholders and
everyone's aware they would need some
time for implementation as well and and
I guess what we're asking not at the
moment but we need to know what that
time frame is
and uh and I think we need to
um ask for the Department to develop a
plan for implementation that uh we can
make sure that this bill is uh uh
properly amended so that uh the
department can't provide for that clean
implementation that I was talking about
um and um I guess my question is how
soon can we have that uh from you
because we we we need to move forward
with this uh we retained it so we could
do this so um uh and I I I for one would
be happy to come in and meet with uh
um members of the department um to to
work on it and um I know my uh friend is
uh pretty busy but uh would you be
think that might be a good good way to
go forward uh short term but I but we
don't have months to get this done we
have days
um what what would be a good plan for us
folks even if it's just excuse me even
if it's just a
um I'm not expecting book chapter and
verse but even um an outline y bullet
pointed outline uh you guys can work on
the details yourself giving us a time
because it'll give us the time frame
which you need to determine some kind of
implementation U because you know as
simple as okay this thing gets passed
let's say it gets signed by the governor
in June of of
2024 it's going to take two or three
months for the Department to budget
determine uh who what additional staff
they need get them hired get them on
board get them trained before you can
then start having educational things so
kind of that that is more of a timeline
what I'm looking for it doesn't have to
be exact to the date um more more
General bullet points and and
subsections than a complete written
Epistle of of
uh that you probably have to send over
you know possibly the Jael car or
something so I think that's something
obviously the department can work on and
get that to you as soon as we can um and
of course we're more than welcome to
anyone any of the representatives coming
in to work with us on it have any
questions or concerns obviously we're
always available um I would say one
piece of that
being the timeline would inevitably be
different and we can work on both
timelines and an estimate to that but
obviously as you know the concern being
might take longer um what I'm getting at
is whether we're doing peace meal as
we've you know potentially discussed if
we're doing the wholesale adoption uh so
you the long and short being the
mechanisms of what we're actually doing
here would of course impact what it
would take for us to implement it and
again we can work on um varying kind of
proposals and again of course they'd be
broad um but again inevitably that would
take more time because we'd have to do
there you had mentioned briefly in your
testimony that your inspectors are
trained under your either General duties
or or other mechanisms and not OSHA
right
um and and part of the I don't know who
the I don't know I don't know what I'm
trying to say here part of what was done
with 1910 was someone made a decision to
look through every single line and
determine what you're doing what you're
not doing what may not be applicable
correct so my point is I'm trying to
make is how different are they do you
have any I mean just so I I I can tell
you I was the one actually did that um
it's been several years at this point
but as you probably note um even just
kind of going through it broadly but
once you're going through it a little
bit more with a fine tooth comb a lot of
the provisions we simply have nothing um
so it's completely absent from our laws
again these are pieces that um as
director roas has testified to that our
inspectors are trained to recognize of
like an obvious safety issue um so you
know it in something that they might go
to OSHA they might go to just the
general standards of the equipment
whatever it may be but for them to be
experts to be going out to these
locations um you know of course they
don't need to know word by word
everything but they need to have a
general sense to say okay I know that
the OSHA standard that we're using now
under the 1910s actually delineates
specific you know inches or feet or you
know whatever it may be for say the um
the space between rungs on ladders that
might be something we don't have so it's
something that they would need to be
trained on again not to the minutia by
any means but to be able to recognize
that that it's like okay this on its
face looks like it might not comply I
need to take a look at this standard I
need to measure this um so that's where
um you know to your overall point the
the issue being that a lot of these
pieces are completely absent from our
laws it's not merely in a lot of cases
of we're adding more safeguards more
standards to something that's already
there obviously you know scaffolding is
something that we have in our rules and
our law that would be a little bit more
robust so it's something that they're
already trained on at least to a point
so it would be an addition to that but
again a lot of this stuff will be under
the
1910s um items that are completely new
to our
laws do do you I just wanted to address
so it's not just general duties it's
chapter lab 277 277a
uh lab rule 600 and the 1400 so it's our
inspectors are well-versed in a number
of statutes I just wanted to make sure
that they weren't getting short shifted
and that they know of one statute they
you know they're pretty knowledgeable
and they it does provide a level of
protection but I just wanted to clarify
that yeah my my impress I we are I'm
aware I think we are aware that uh
there's more than just the general
duties Clause um everything doesn't come
under that but but I would say too much
much stuff does come under that um and
um my observation and see if this is uh
if you agree um the
uh where the uh there is a uh Department
of Labor Standard and an oia standard uh
they don't they don't generally conflict
with each other um they might look um
different they might be worded
differently and in many cases the OSHA
standard is more is more robust more uh
detailed um but as I read through and
and did um comparisons of you know the
two um I didn't see conflicts and I
don't think there's going to be
something that uh would be deemed safe
under the uh department of labor
standards um and suddenly unsafe under
OSHA standards that's the exception
being will we just identified with the
um Environmental Services yes yes didn't
hear you I'm sorry the exception is the
Environmental Services concern that
we'll be addressing right yes yes the
equipment that U is
uh um made made made overseas and
therefore
not uh not not working for us so but
that's something we need to figure out
um do you have an idea um
when uh would be good for uh
representative infantine and myself to
uh come meet with the
Department I mean you need some time to
to I'd say both director roas and myself
can make ourselves available generally
whenever works for um the both of you we
would have to speak to you know
commissioner Maryfield and W
commissioner Albert as I would imagine
that they would want to be involved as
well too um but of course you know they
generally obviously they're busy but
they do try to be available as well um
so to the question off the top of our
head there's no specific dates or times
that we could propose at this time but
it's something that I think we can put
together in very short order that works
for
everybody how how about uh you go back
to the department and um let us know
when would be a good time and I think I
just heard you say Deputy Commissioner
Albert yes she has ascended to the
deputy commissionership
well
deserved um and I for anybody who
doesn't know um Deputy Commissioner
Ogden is now in the governor's office
and gone from the Department of Labor so
um he will be missed
um ahead thank you Mr chairman um it
sounds like you want to have an advisory
committee for implementation of the
ooser standards could that be part of
this bill going forward could be and
also um could
the could we have a permanent
subcommittee or if in addition to or
in in you know in if you don't do the
advisory committee could we have a
permanent subcommittee so we can have um
um quarterly meetings or quarterly
updates on what is being done um after
law certainly
possible and one final update would you
mind
um looking through some of this and
we've looked through it for years now
and and I want to thank um this
gentleman here for working on that um if
there wasn't implementation over time
could the easy stuff be done first and
then the medium stuff A year later and
then the hard stuff be worked on through
the entire things that have the the you
know the tentacles that go out into
other Industries to handle um that like
not using an aluminum ladder at
electrical if it's not in our standards
easy stuff that we could I think again
the the potential difficulty um without
you know delving into the minutia of the
1910s is where there's cross references
pieces like that I would say say the the
other piece which is I guess would be
for all of us to determine like what
constitutes the easy ones what
constitutes which which I think would go
back to cost at the end of the day more
than likely in implementation um but
perhaps that probably requires a little
bit more input from the stakeholders um
you know because again the until you
know the good example is the
Environmental Services until they
brought that up it's not something that
I think the department nor the committee
knew would be um such a large project
and a large cost to
Implement um so to your question I mean
I I think it's definitely possible um on
its face but you know that that's that
answer could change in the future the
more that we actually look into what the
mechanisms and procedure of that would
really be at the end of the day um but
you know I think if it can work it could
be a good idea in the sense that uh it
allows to kind of Peace meal and slow
walk this thing while updating the
standards um and again that's something
that will take the time to look into as
much as we can you know given our time
constraints of what that actually might
entail on our end and again the the the
other caveat
being it might be difficult if we're
identifying what's you know
easy difficult you know and we're kind
of uh you know figuring out what's that
are those actually you know contained
within is is if we say subpart d is that
is of subpart D easy or are there pieces
of that that 90% of it is very easy
implementation but there's the 10%
that's going to cause this large cost to
Dees I'm not sure about that so that's
kind of hard to say on its face again so
it's another concern and consideration I
think we would all have to have and at
the end of the day I think we all want
this to be as streamlined and simplified
for everybody um and I would worry and
have concerns if we are adopting
portions of
subparts piece meal um how difficult
that might be then to implement and
understand by the stakeholders but again
that's something that we'd have to work
through and uh look into a little bit
more in depth I would
say y so even just even just identifying
what PPE is if I can go to 277 and look
and see okay what PPP PPE requires a
mask of a certain standard or gloves of
a certain standard or your hand gloves
for you know identifying something needs
to be a certain Mill per I mean that
kind of stuff is not in there and I know
it's probably in 1910 could we slow walk
that to saying okay well these are you
have to have gloves but this is the
standard that we would be looking for
now or this is the standard that we
would be looking for in three years or
this is the changes that we need to
implement to make sure that it happens
or instead of a three-point harness you
now need a fourpoint harness to hang off
a bridge or something like that I mean
stuff would be easy for for somebody
like me that reads it of course and then
you know you guys have the you again I I
I think that's definitely possible and
again the the the concern that I think
that we would have is just in the sense
of if we're taking peace meal from each
part of this you know if we're just
taking full subp Parts it's relatively
easy I would say of now we're doing subp
Parts D through F and now we're doing G
through J whatever it may be but once we
start taking okay now we're
doing these Provisions from subpart C
but we're holding off on these other
Provisions from subpart C it could just
become more of a project um not that you
know we're you know afraid of hard work
by any means but again I think that one
of the intents of this bill was to get
the standards one get them more robust
but get them more out there and I think
that was kind of your line of
questioning earlier of we want these
stakeholders to actually know what these
standards are and what the Department's
going to be going towards um so again it
just might be a little bit more
difficult and again this is just me kind
of spi Balling on it you know I'm not
without actually delving into it but if
we are taking peace meal from each subp
part the further we delve down the kind
of more difficult it does get a little
bit in the sense that okay now we have
to remember in four months we have to go
back to subpart C and re-evaluate these
are the pieces we're missing from
subpart C that we haven't implemented
yet are these uh easy that we want to
implement now are they a little bit more
difficult um so that that's the only
concern that would have in that sense if
that makes sense and and I I guess the
the other concern that I continue to
have is that when this bills uh signed
into law when it becomes effective um
all of the um current safety standards
go away and we we have to make sure that
we don't leave uh a vacuum with no
standards um covering vast sections of
the uh uh public sector Workforce um and
I'm wondering if if rather than picking
and choosing which standards to
implement um perhaps there can be some
language added into the uh an amendment
that would um impact the implementation
process in other
words how will the department be viewing
um employers who are um new to the OSHA
standards um can we put and again you
don't want to say that we're going to
give everybody a pass um because you you
don't do that now um but uh is there
something we can do in order to
um give
employers a grace period of some
sort so I can address how we do it
currently okay um so right now if we
come to a location and they have just
passed their budget and they you know
and they have and that they didn't raise
any of the safety concerns that we
notifi that we re recognized during our
inspection we look at it and we triage
what needs to be done immediately uh
what are the hurdles and then we babysit
the case to make sure it's all done
within a reasonable amount of time so
for example there was an elevator that
needed to be fixed but uh because of the
current economy the piece that needed to
be made by special order wasn't going to
be ready for six months well is the
elevator able to be safely maintained or
operated until then no okay we're going
to suspend that unit um um adopt new
safety standards in the meantime do you
have an additional elevator yes great um
and then you know so that there's and so
we just we wait and you know but we're
babysitting we don't close that case um
there was another instance in which a
boiler was being improperly maintained
well you know well we had allocated this
amount of money for an ice cream uh
County Ice Cream was was a town I think
was going to put a little ice cream
stand said well you know does that take
precedence over the boiler in which
could go boom uh no so they were able to
reallocate the funds for the ice cream
so nobody got ice cream this past summer
sorry uh but they got a new boiler um
for that location so it's you know so we
were able to discuss what needs to be
done immediately and then create a
reasonable timeline for the other things
to get done we're not talking years
we're talking months um and then it's
monitored by an inspector um so this
would C you know if if we do have
additional you know
new standards there's going to be a lot
more cases to babysit this is where our
staffing needs are going to become
stretched then though and and I think
that was um part of our discussion in
the last couple sessions here that um
I've said it over and over again the
department is not a punitive Department
it's a um uh Department that helps
people get um get it together so perhaps
I'm going to suggest this and see where
it goes but perhaps it's better to just
adopt all the standards all at once with
the emphasis that um the department will
continue operating the way it does um
helping people to learn the new
standards um and the new adjustments
they need to make and um as you said
babysit the the issue uh to make sure
the people come come along
um that way we don't have any gaps in
standards no confusion as to which
standards are in place and which ones
aren't um they're all in place but we're
not going to whack you over the head
with it um we're going to help you get
get in line um I guess I throw that to
think
um I'm not sure I really want to go on
the record is passing a piece of
legislation knowing full well I don't
expect the Department of Labor to
enforce it the way it's been
written you know I but but they're
they're simply continuing to operate the
way they operate right now if someone's
unaware of the current
standards um they don't necessarily get
uh the book thrown at them true so we
are operating as the law is designed the
law requires us to be reasonable so you
know there is a reasonable standard so
there is a you know like there's a
shutdown provision if safety standards
are not being met such that there is
danger of life and limb we are evalu
that's not the first goto there are
punitive measures that can be
implemented that's not our first goto we
don't assess civil penalties you know
this is you know the safety unit is not
a money generator at all we're not you
know so it's something in which we use
if we need to escalate but rarely do we
have an employer who is doing this
intentionally it's we're education
forward and we've noticed that most of
the viations that we see are just due to
ignorance um with you know good
intentions but ignorance so we are you
know so it's just education figuring out
how fast it can be implemented you know
for instance if they're missing an eyew
watch station that can be done very
quickly we don't if they ask for a
30-day extension that's a no um but if
they're asking for a piece that needs to
be specially made in China uh and you
know that's we're going to be reasonable
an understanding of when that's going to
be accommodated but we're going to make
sure that that
condition that's currently being uh that
exists isn't endangering anyone in the
meantime so so I guess the point is that
we would not be passing um a law that uh
gives the department a pass on not
enforcing you will be enforcing but you
will enforce the way you enforce now
that you you will be helping people to
come into compliance um so I I I guess
it seems to work better that way than to
uh
be slow walking the um which standards
are being uh U implemented when um that
seems like an overly complicated process
um either way we'd be implementing it
right Mr
chairman the
the the one thing I seem to continue to
be confused on here is
why the bill has to be
written where it removes all of
something and implements something
else why can't the existing law about
General duties 281 277 1718 4600 1400
still be in place they're utilizing and
then Implement complete sections of
certain parts of 1910 like the ladders
is one of them you keep mentioning there
a whole 25 p pages about ladders and
then there's something about um uh
chains uh hoisting chains you know about
the certain um size they have to
be
so did I miss something or is this just
kind of the thought process where you
take what's you got now move it aside
Implement all of
1910 why can't you keep what you have
Implement certain sections of 1910 in
their entirety
I would suggest that that would be
confusing because essentially employers
would have to figure out which sections
are are OSHA and which sections are
under the um old statute and um it would
be very difficult for them to keep track
of that um and frankly I asked for some
help with the Deputy Commissioner in
drafting the bill and it was his thought
that um the cleanest thing to do is
repeal the whole
um all of the do standards and replace
them all at once so no one is confused
as to what the standard is
um so the the thought is that with
what's being used now and implementing
complete sections of
1910 that there's con
uh conflict in consistency well I mean
as we look through the side by side that
uh um attorney Gardner put together
course
um you wouldn't want to have um an OSHA
piece and a do piece they're similar
they probably are not in conflict with
each other but they might be in in small
ways and again that would be incredibly
confusing to say we're going to keep the
old standard and the new standard at the
same
time because um you'd be covering the
same um uh standards
in two different ways in many instances
in many instances as uh attorney Gardner
pointed out there is no standard in the
in the current do um and I mean frankly
filling in those gaps is what we're
trying to do and uh getting that done
sooner rather than later I think is a
good thing and having the department
helping employers learn and understand
where where these new uh standards um
are taking place I I
think I mean a lot of these
standards don't depending on what kind
of employer you are um a lot of the
standards don't mean anything to certain
employers um they don't I
mean in the schools they don't use
ladders a lot so the um although the
custodians
do um but um but in terms of uh most
departments within the school don't have
to worry about a lot of these standards
um only the the maintenance department
so I I just I find the idea of
implementing it in pieces to be
incredibly confusing and um difficult
I'll give you an example I'm just
reading this and again I'm reading some
of the stuff for first time in depth do
uh period 142 temporary labor camps
there's eight pages on temporary labor
camps I'm not sure that's a really
important thing to be implemented right
now um for our municipalities to have
but if it is implemented it won't matter
because there are no temporary labor
camps um so then I got to read all the
other stuff this is what I'm afraid of
I'm afraid of someone going out and you
know hiring someone said okay 1910 is
the law city of Manchester goes out and
is's going to hire someone at the cost
of about all in
$125,000 a year okay to study and
Implement 1910 and they're going to put
you know put rules together for I I
don't know ladders labor camps uh uh
chain uh couplings how they're supposed
to be done and all these other things
and
um and
then if someone's actually following
what we're telling them to do
we Implement a
law the um the cost associated with some
of these things and and
um again I'm I'm remiss for not having
read these thousand Pages which I guess
I'm G to have to start reading but
um you
um I'm I'm not trying to dumb it
down I I just want to implement things
that are are so I you know when I took
my OSHA 10 okay the things that I was
taught basically or fall safety
trenching Hees you know those are the
three big ones that seem to cause most
of the the injuries and and I want to
hit the things that are probably the
ones that are most
important um and that was the only thing
I was trying to do Brian not try to to
do anything halfway or to to but
implementing some things that
um I mean I'm not sure they're going to
enforce much on labor camps and ladders
and and I I think what each employer
will do is they'll go through and
they'll say this doesn't apply to us
this doesn't apply to us this doesn't
apply to us these do and they'll focus
on the on the pieces that do and ignore
the ones that have nothing to do with
them um that that'll
be you know different for the different
types of employers and and a lot of uh
public sector workers like
firefighters theyve got standards above
and beyond and aside from um OSHA that
they um that they adhere to and
uh so that I mean
they I I think the employers and and I
don't think it falls on us to memorize
the Thousand Pages um I that's not going
to be my object objective here be being
somewhat aware of how they align and
again the work of attorney Gardener is
very helpful here
um but
um I don't I don't think this is as
difficult as we're making it out to be
um there will be a lot of standards that
don't apply to any public sector um
employers there will be
um depending on what kind of employer
they are the um they will focus on the
standards that are
relevant and that's you if if the
Consultants that the Department of Labor
um U hires
um they'll be hiring people that
probably have gone through the Keen
State program um which um is the
uh OSHA training center for um for New
Hampshire um
but as you know Mr chairman I'm always
cognizant about passing a bill out of um
the house that we can
get signed by by the governor into law
and
um I'm concerned that if we pass this
and we go to a senate hearing we have
too many kind
of oh maybe balls in the air with with
with what we're trying to to tell them
that we want them to do well and iess
that's reason and I guess what I'm
looking to is let's get the Department
of Labor to help us with uh the the
details on that um um I don't know if it
would help if we met with you before you
uh implement the uh come up with that
plan or whether it's
uh in in which case probably early next
week would be a good time to get
together um and then and maybe what we
ought to do is is you know take it uh
give it two weeks um talk to you early
next week and then um the the following
week um have an outline so that when we
do go to the Senate I agree we we need
to be able to say this is how this thing
is going to be rolled out but I I I
guess I rather than us um trying to um
micromanage this I don't think that is
our role um that's your role um we're
going to ask you to micromanage it and
and figure out the cleanest way to um
roll this thing out um what is the best
effective date um if there's any reason
to have multiple effective dates um
where certain aspects of this are are
done um we'd like to hear about that um
what are we going to do about the dees
uh concerns
um you know we need to have a discussion
with the uh commissioner about the um
Prospect of a 50-50 cost sharing for um
um for employers and um
and just
the I guess we're looking to you the
best way to roll this out um and we want
to go to the Senate with a u a plan that
says this is doable this is uh
worthwhile this is going to you know
make our workplaces uh more safe we
heard some last week about how uh you
know the uh uh slips and falls and those
types of things are the most common
types of uh uh workplace injuries I
don't think we're trying to address the
most common ones we're trying to address
the most serious ones and having more
complete safety standards we'll make
sure that the serious injuries and the
and the um fatalities on the job um
they're not common now we want to make
them far less common um non-existent if
possible um that's the objective of
um yep Mr chairman if I if I may please
I I guess I'm sitting here wondering you
know um there's a couple of things that
are going through my head as we're
discussing this but if there's things
within the 1910 that don't apply and we
are throwing out a broad net of safety
standards that may or may not be
followed or may or may not be read or
known by half the people or half of the
the public
entities I guess I wonder what the value
is in that and the other thing that I I
guess I would like to share is is
something that I experienced yesterday
with road paving in our town um with the
state do uh you know and and when I
experienced this my first thought came
right back to the subcommittee and the
discussions that we're having and who's
in charge of what and what safety
Protocols are F so I'm driving up the
road and they're Paving on my Lane so
the flagger directs me to the other the
other lane to go around it and as I'm
going up and around it the Flagger is
alongside the road and it's a narrow
road talking with other do or other
employees of Continental Paving I'm not
sure but they're occupying a space in my
Lane so now I'm forced to cross back
into where they're Paving where the
equipment is so I'm sitting there saying
why are these guys standing where
they're standing in the road because
that's just an accident waiting to
happen and now they're forcing me to
drive on T that hasn't been put down and
I'm getting it all splattered over my
car and I'm in them now the travel Lane
of the paving guy so I immediately
thought back to our safety standards
who's following what and here we have
private sector and public sector working
side by side on a job who's following
what and the flagger could get hit those
employees could have gotten hit if I had
my phone in my hand and was not paying
hit and part of what brings us here is
uh when uh Tom wooden uh was killed some
years ago on a public sector job um and
uh you that's uh part of the inspiration
for U for being here so I I agree with
you excuse me representative I where was
that location no no no no no nice try
that's that's why we're here is to make
and
the um we had talked
about I had mentioned um implementing
certain parts of it and and and you'd
rather go with a full thing but then you
also full full
1910 uh and then but then you wanted
to exclude certain things right you
wanted some especially this one with
this machine is is made
overseas so I'm okay with one I find
them both I find the same thing and it's
saying it said a different way if you
want to implement all of 19 and exclude
them things or just implment part of
1910 it doesn't matter to me either way
but as long as there's the ability which
you seem amable to to certain things
that may not be either feasible right
now or too cost costly right
now and I I guess um that's something
that we may may need to work out exactly
how to word that but but we were talking
prior to the uh um meeting today day of
uh um possibly having some some form of
um temporary grandfathering um that
allows um the dees for example to uh
continue using their uh very expensive
um effective and non-compliant uh
equipment um for a period of time it'll
have to be um replaced eventually
anyways um so when it's replaced it
should be replaced with something that
is compliant
but doing something like that I think I
think works um
uh but um I just I I don't think the uh
partial implementation of of the of the
standards is is is going to work that's
going to cause confusion but basically
where there is a problem and
um if we can come up with a general
provision for um
uh uh temporary grandfathering maybe
maybe that would work um but um and and
have the department authorized to figure
out where that fits and where it doesn't
and I guess I'm going to ask you to
think about that and when we um do get
together um perhaps that's something
that U we can um try to work on
so L thank you Mr chairman um I'm a fan
of the slow walk um I'm not a fan of
dropping dropping all of it um I know
we've been in discussions for over a
year the department know knows the
direction we want to go um coming from
an area with very small towns anything
we Implement within the next two or
three years is going to take them two or
three years through the budget Cycles or
we need to you know get this new trash
compactor that has you know the two-hand
thing on it you operate by your foot I
mean stuff like that um so I I'm happy
to be part of this but we have to be
aware that the smaller towns that only
have a few employees that have to go to
town meeting and town budget and work
this out and this out and and get the
funding for it and raise the taxes for
it that we give them the ability to do
that without having open cases for years
of these towns so we have to have
extended um government oversight into
these areas um I mean I like a
three-year a three-year idea of easy
hard medium and hard I mean if we have
to Grant exceptions we should be able to
Pivot that and have the department grant
exceptions or grandfathers or extension
or anything like that so we have the
ability to be flexible and through the
time we've always wanted to do with the
New Hampshire way we don't want to come
in and have the heavy-handed of Oso on
the backs of the public employers um or
have the fines or have the things with
the plan that we were talking about and
all that other stuff I mean we want to
do it our way we should be able to let
the department do it their way and we
should be able to you know not hold
their hand but you know say hey we want
we we want to see something change and I
think it's been made clear through the
last year we've been talking about this
that this is coming one way or another
let's do it together yeah
um and and I I guess the temporary
grandfathering uh is is something that
would I I think do what you're looking
for if I'm not mistaken that essentially
it would
allow a uh an employer to say look we
realize that there's a standard here
that U
is implemented as of
June 1st 2025 let's say
um but we but we need time to make the
adjustment that that uh grandfathering
could occur but it would have to you
know you'd have to say it can only go on
if you know for a threeyear period or
something like that and then um then
they would have to make uh make the
adjustment but it would give them time
to budget give them time to plan um and
um uh
you know get ready basically um but they
they they would understand and and that
might be the the piece so I guess I'm
going to ask you folks to think about
that that idea and
um when we start crafting an amendment
that's something that uh I think if we
could say we're going to adopt these
standards as of this
date but we are going to allow um a
period time to get uh uh for the
employers to get fully um compliant does
that make sense to you as long as they
have they understand that they have to
maintain the current
standards until they have you know so
for instance if that Machinery that they
don't want to replace to bring to 1910
breaks they're going to have to repair
it at least to current standards and
operated under current standards until
the the grandfathering period is over
um we don't want to create a
misunderstanding where they think they
have a free-for-all until that
grandfather period is
concern
okay
removing um removing the standards could
we just maybe have language in there
that says where that there's going to be
a minimum standard and then there's
going to be an OSHA standard effective
2025 but they need to maintain the
minimum standard now and in 2025
there'll be an enhan enhanced standard
just like when we pass you new building
codes and when we pass this or that this
is coming in 2025 you have to have
certain things or fire code or
electrical code stuff like that that
we're updating could we do that same
thing here there's a minimum standard
that we're going to keep in place until
we have the enhanced standard standard
would that be helpful instead of just
wiping everything out and then bringing
hammer I think it can kind of cut both
ways I mean to your point I think it
could be helpful in that you know of
course we're maintaining the current
standards um and informing all the
stakeholders that this is what's coming
down um to the other point that's prob
been discussed today
though depending on how it's implemented
I could see parts of it being confusing
you know if people are looking at one
and say okay I see there's in essence
two different standards for ladders of
our current standards say
are basically the same to a point and
the ocean standards are more
robust again it could just cause a
little bit of confusion so I mean it
really boils down to how that's actually
implemented I think that that is
potentially feasible but mechanically
and procedurally how that goes will be
key there I would say thank you and
there's a followup Mr chairman
um so what would prevent you today from
going back to your office implementing a
new ladder standard sending that over to
Jael car in your 1400 and getting it
done without our
intrusion um nothing would specifically
and never has um you know hindered that
per se um obviously with the last couple
of years with these discussions of
course you know the it's it's kind of
been back and forth of where these would
really go if they statutory law versus
administrative rules but yes to your
point we are able to do do that um
obviously as I'm sure the committee is
aware that if we were to say try and do
the whole of 1910s in our administrative
rules that would be a very very lengthy
process with JL car because you know
they have to go through line by line
even if we say this is carbon copied
from OSHA they nonetheless have to still
go through it line by line which which
is the reason why Deputy Commissioner
Ogden uh said it would be uh more
effective simply uh reference 1910
rather than um
trying to adopt piece by piece by piece
by piece um and and there are per
sections of it that are irrelevant to
the public sector Employers in um New
Hampshire but you you adopt the whole
thing and you um uh you use a pieces
that are relevant and again relevant to
different
employers but I guess
uh
I hear hear what you're saying about uh
um maintaining the old standards while
moving towards the new standards I'm not
sure how you put that into into the bill
um and it would be confusing to have two
different standards in place at the same
time
um and and
um would it be feasible to Simply um re
reference Uh current standards say oceia
standards are the one in place
um and they will be um fully implemented
by XD they're imple they're adopted as
of this date fully
implemented some period of time down the
road a couple years later um and in the
meantime um employers will be expected
to uh maintain at least the current
level of uh
safety so we're talking about the
difference between an effective date and
something actually in the bill that's
stating when um some sort of Grandfather
right I mean I I think we can handle it
the same as we do with an effective date
where it's just States you know until
the such time you know you know I think
you're talking about a five-year Grace
period or grandfather or threee so you
know Machinery that is that is currently
up to code uh with respect to the uh can
maintain the the 1400 lab rules as of X
date um until such time until the three
years is up something to that degree
okay
okay another
idea let's go go
ahead so one of the one of the things
I'm concerned about is
capacity um you currently have an
obligation to
review um an an employee has an
obligation every two years to look at
their plan and revise their plan and you
have an obligation to make sure that's
happening so that based on the number of
employers in the state is a big lift so
that's number one um number two when was
when was the last time that there was a
wholesale uh you know re revision of um
of the lab rules relative to safety and
health because you talk about you talk
about big gaps currently in this that
are exist in the current lab
rules so when was the last time they did
a wholesale kind of so it has not been
wholesale but just this past um a few
months ago we did revise our 600 rules
review of update them um we had I we
were the plan is to do the 1400 rules
that is going to be revised uh this year
so we do review them um and so under
commissioner Maryfield he does have us
all on a schedule to look at our lab
rooms and review them um annually so um
we have done that for the 600s in the
next plan is to do that for the
1400s we having a little trouble hearing
you because of sorry so just reviewed
our we just reviewed our 600 lab rules
and then we're going to be reviewing our
1400 lab rules uh there was some
discussion about whether or not it would
be impacted by this bill um and whether
we should tackle them or not that's the
only thing that's I think at our that
that was that's why we did the 600 first
um but then the plan was to go over the,
1400 so we do review them
annually and what do you if I could what
is the guidance that you use when you're
revising elabor what is the standard
that you that you uh Target yourself
towards so we look at what our current
you know we look at our case studies you
know is there something that's being
that's causing confusion uh is there
something that is not is routinely not
being adhered to and why we try to
address that with our you know revisions
rules is an attorney
um discretionary enforcement I was an
inspector for years the city of
Manchester we were Guided by zoning
ordinances the fire rules all of those
kinds of things work as comp is Guided
by the
law what I'm hearing you say in some
cases is that it is a
discretionary um situation where you
interpret Things based on your
experience and and all of those kinds of
things that come together and I
understand that so but there is a gap
Gap
though would you agree that there
without a proper standard there
potentially could be a
gap in the way that this is in the way
that you interpret things and you go
from one inspector to the other
inspector to another inspector without a
without a good
standard the possibility for
discretionary enforcement would you
agree that that's a potential there is
there's um so during the course of an
inspection you're talking about I'm
talking about one
you take if what do you have three or
four inspectors I think I have two
currently with one opening it's been
open for a while let get them fills I am
trying so I also have D is here so I'll
be talking to them about one of the uh
positions that I have open do you have I
mean Ina in the case of comp you have
case law you have the law of the on the
books you have all these kinds of things
that enter into how decisions are made
so the question I have is is if absent a
standard like oser or some other
National Standard how how do you how do
you uh overcome that that discretionary
potentially discretionary enforcement so
there is a reasonable standard that we
need to maintain so a person can
challenge my inspector's you know
position which again I review um and if
they can challenge it and it gets goes
to a superior court review so so that's
where and so that's where the
justification sometimes we do lean on
OSHA to support why our position is
reasonable and we try to tack it on to
either the facts and circumstances of
the case where you know it was
reasonable for them for us to say you
need to implement the training your your
safety program as you wrote it um you
know because that person was not taught
the proper well was not taught to
utilize directionals and you're not
enforcing your safety program or they
were taught and you're not disciplining
them for not using it um oh so that's so
the facts will either support our Justus
our our reasonable recommend our um
corrective action plan um or we can rely
on a gen you know what is generally done
within that um industry like industry
standard as reasonable so there is that
check of of the court that we you know
so that's why we do off you know we're
not you know during um coid a hazmat
suit would have been the most effective
way to protect someone but is that
reasonable so um you know so that's
something that would allow allowed us
some just you know we had to do research
to figure out how close to those lines
can we get and uphold the reasonable
standards in a court of
law one issue that came up here that I
think is um is worthwhile
discussing uh there our standards that
currently exist for prisons for nursing
homes uh in fact OSHA doesn't cover some
of these I don't oia doesn't cover
prisons it's a separate standard so when
we talk about enforcing uh OSHA
standards for the prisons it's a
different standard firefighters have a a
whole different you know so I as you as
we talk through this how we accommodate
those differences um something we we
need to talk about because if we were to
drop the OSHA standard on there's going
to be all these gaps that that are not
going to apply so they currently what we
do in those issues again we have this
reasonableness and so like when we talk
about how our inspectors are not trained
specific specifically to oia they're you
really have to look at them as more like
expert researchers trying to figure so
we do again inspect you know serious
bodily injuries to Firefighters uh you
know more frequently than we would like
um but that's just the nature of the job
unfortunately um and when we look at
that we are looking at the fire
standards you know are they adhering to
the training so we're not looking at
OSHA we're not looking you at our own
laws per se we are looking at other you
know the other laws from the outside
held okay and the the only final thing I
would say is that the beneficiaries of
good safety programs are the communities
and other people uh the the businesses
and the communities and stuff and I'm
really surprised that the insurance
industry is not
here because they were here initially
when we started talking about about
safety standards and they have been the
beneficiaries in fact a more recent um
article by beton Court uh shows a a ma a
significant curve significant uh slope
in terms of cost savings for
employers uh so they've been the
beneficiaries of of of safety and health
programs and other things over the
course of the years and stuff that we
negotiated uh with them some years ago
so I'm surprised they're not here saying
that we would perhaps like better uh
enforcement better law
to help um to help with providing safety
and finally slips and Falls uh account
for thousands of injuries in New
Hampshire by your own numbers thousands
over 10,000 uh slips and Falls alone uh
were reported by in your biannual
report and we should see another
biannual report soon correct one's
coming out in October October 1st it's
du I believe that that is correct
representative I know it's it is
forthcoming at a minimum though it's
been worked on for some time do you have
any sense of how much money will be
turned back to the uh State of New
back I
believe and this is just off the top of
my head just memory I believe it was
close to 3 million for the last fiscal
year um obviously we're in the infancy
of the new fiscal year so hard to tell
of like any sort of projections um and I
I would have no reason to talk to our
accounting Bureau at this juncture for
that but I believe that it was a shade
under three million was to give back to
the general fund in the last fiscal year
from the Department of Labor 2 million
the last F correct
you thank you Mr sorry thank you Mr
chairman um hearing some of the um
discussion we just had was could there
be an adoption date for 1910 could there
be an effective date for 1910 and could
there be an enforcement date for
1910 could those
be utilized to get where we want to be
could we say we're going to adopt them
in 25 we're going to they'll become
effective in 26 and we're going to start
27 is that something that we would be
able to do as legislators
to do that for you guys or is it
something that you would not want us to
do because it would tie your hands for
effective dates or enforcement dates it
would also give you guy obviously the
department enough time to say okay yeah
we're they're dropping this in our lap
in 25 we're going to have to you know
effective it in 26 and we're going to
have to sign enforcing it in 27 that
also gives you three years to notify the
200 M municipalities that we that you
oversee or things like that to get that
ball
rolling in 25 or 24 or whatever
I would say on its face it definitely
sounds like a feasible um implementation
schedule caveat being that um obviously
director roas and I can't speak to
certain aspects of that you know when
we're talking funding um things that are
the commissioner level type things so
again on its face I think that that
would be feasible potentially and again
it's it all goes back to mechanically
and procedurally how this actually is
implemented but a schedule like that I
think would be
feasible like boots on the ground you
know for the inspectors and for what we
would need to do for finding you know
new Consultants um establishing that
program but again there's other pieces
well yes um that would also give you the
ability to say okay well we have these
standards this is what we need to
enforce them we need two more um
inspectors we need another support
person we need an assistant commissioner
another assistant commissioner for that
area to enforce that could that be part
of the I don't want to say enforcement
mechanism but could that be
self-sufficient to the point where you
could say okay we need three more
employees we give back $3 million we
need to withhold 400,000 out of that to
keep these three
employees yeah if if I'm understanding
your question correctly I think that
yeah that could be helpful for us in the
sense that obviously we can uh do
analysis um but it's a guess at the end
of the day until we start implementing
um at least to a point of what the
department would need for you know you
know more funding well not funding
rather because again as it's been stated
we give back to the general fund but for
more positions um you know where the
give back would end up be projection
wise and everything um so we could kind
of re-evaluate and say yeah we came here
we said that we need x amount of
positions of Consultants given the
volume of stakeholders that have come to
the department we now realize we need y
amount which is an increase so I think
that could be helpful in that sense
again just the the standard caveat being
that there's you know POS positions and
pieces of that that frankly we're just
not privy to in our
positions last fall was go ahead
um and I can certainly understand all
that there's a lot there's a lot of
open-ended questions that we have today
um that we've been working towards
closing the Gap in this legislation get
it through and then get it over to the
Senate
um if we did slow walk
it which the the impl through the
implementation process um what support
would you want from us to say okay well
we can't do this in a year can we adjust
this
date would you want to come back to us
and have it have us do another amendment
or would you rather have this law saying
this is what we're going to do get it
done by this time or we're going to be
filing this is it is it something that
we
can just try find trying to find a happy
medium so everybody's happy here yeah
yeah I would say yeah communication is
always key with these things because you
know the last thing any of us would want
is you know we kind of have a general
agreement and then three years down the
line you know we have to come here and
testify and say yeah this isn't working
out for anybody um so again hard to say
on its face right now but I I I think it
would obviously be helpful if it's kind
of a
um if it's something that as we're going
through if we are going to do a slow
walk implementation that it's uh a
coordination between us and the
legislature um in you know us updating
you guys to say this is where we're at
this is what we're seeing um and trying
to get ahead of potential issues in the
future then how I also Invision our
audits if you do a slow walk process our
audits will be kind of done in under the
each category so what it looks like
under so we can give them help the towns
and the counties plan you're under
you're you know you're in current
compliance with X but please note that
when we go into the next one these are
the things you're going to be needing to
plan to address and then by the time we
get to the final stage this is what
we're going to be looking for so that
they can also project and as we get
feedback from the towns with the various
you know issues that they're presenting
for wire white that would not be
possible we could bring that back to
you and I I'm attracted to what
representative avalani is uh suggesting
um and I guess I'm going to say again
that
uh I think we need guidance from the
Department as exactly how that would
um and I'm not sure what the difference
between adopting and effective date
is um but essentially there's it's not a
bad idea to say okay we we are I'm
making a commitment that these are going
to be our standards we're not we're
going to and and frankly the the repeal
date um would be delayed as well you
would leave the current standards in
place you would commit to the OSHA
standards
um give time for everybody to get ready
the department the employers everyone
has uh a gap in time but the law says
we're going here and this is the date
um if you if you could work on that so
that we can put that into an amendment I
think that would
uh that would be I think would be
helpful for everybody it
would reduce a lot of the anxiety around
this Mr chairman I have just one um
comment about the just a little
housekeeping of the bill if you look at
the original bill that was filed it
talks about implementing
1910 letter D through Z with the
exception of U
so I have the outline of what a through
z is and you that you want excluded is
coid 19 items V WX and Y are reserved
and there's nothing there so I think we
through uh
whatever
T and then part Z because I don't want
to implement something here part v
through Y which has nothing there and
could be just you know attorney Garner
you do you recall what
uh that reserved section is I I I I I
think it is literally just reserved for
when OSHA is if they choose to implement
an entirely new standard you know you're
not adding to um you know we want
ladders or scaffolding to be a little
bit more safe there's some new things
where they say and I would say I don't
know his torically but my guess is
subpart U up until 2020 was probably
reserved so I think it's for scenarios
like that so they're not kind of adding
on uh ZZ AA um and they just have you
know a through z so I in in that sense
that's how I understand it to be
reserved it's not something I've
researched by any means um but I think
that's really all it is at the end of
the day and it's subpart um uh
representative infanti is pointing out
subpart C is also reserved is that
probably something that was repealed at
some point uh again it's not something
that I've researched by any means my
guess just speculatively would be that
they probably intended to have one of
the initial subparts um Reserve just in
case they needed to do what I would
consider more like housekeeping
definition section something along those
lines so you're not adding something
that really should be at the start of a
law into like subpart Z or somewhere
there so it's like up front people can
actually see it again that's just a
though your your build GL section A
through
so want I don't want I want I don't want
to put something in there that
we have to follow WX and Y right when we
don't know what they are yet what they
Som
right
committee I guess um
I would ask that you folks uh send an
email to representative infantine and
myself uh suggesting a um a date to get
together next week um time and date and
um
there's my schedule is reasonably open
after Monday um I don't know what your
schedule
is
well depends on any given day I'm sorry
okay if you could just make a a
suggestion or a couple of suggestions as
to when we might get together
um hopefully we can um Iron some of this
stuff out uh on the side and then uh
bring it back to this group and I guess
I would suggest that we will not meet
next week but would would meet the
following week to um put that
together thank you thank
adjourned uh I I I don't want to put
Tyler on the
spot but at some point I would like to
hear from the from the firefighters
relative to how oer and the the national
standards for fire the Govern
firefighters um how those integrate uh
and I don't expect you answer that now
uh I would suspect that you know there's
not a standard in the fire station for
the stairs being slippery it's not under
ocean it's not under you know current
NFPA standards but so being interested
to hear how those and if there's
anything as we draft this uh as it
relates to Firefighters or prisons or
other nursing homes if there is
something that we should take into
you